realistically 98 and some people say
it's 99.9
of all scripts submitted are
unreadable
how do most non-professional
screenwriters create plot
often it's the same as professional
screenwriters
but professional screenwriters
can evaluate what they're creating
whereas non-professionals
don't have the ability to
[Music]
eyeball their material at a professional
critique level
so that they'll get excited about an
idea they have
and it can either be too derivative
where it's
been used in way
too many movies or tv shows or stage
plays
so that most people
wouldn't be interested in it unless
the execution of it is extraordinary
which kind of by definition
a non-professional scriptwriter is
generally not
capable of doing now some people are
just out of the box geniuses
and that's different but
not only is that extremely rare but
uh anders eriksen in his book peak
said that they
looked everywhere for prodigies who
were out of the box and just
could do it
with no training as good as the best
people they said those people do not
exist
and they've scoured the earth for them
you hear about them
but it's not true so that for instance
say someone has an innate ability at
chess
and maybe they were a prodigy as it
added as a kid
but didn't
push their capabilities
and they may still still perceive
themselves as a prodigy but if you put
them up against a genuine chess master
they've never found anybody who
without the proper training could go all
the way
uh and i'd never heard that before i
thought there was such a thing as
prodigy anders eriksen calls it the
prodigy myth and they
pretty much categorically disproved it
you know and i think that writers who
come out of left field and who never had
any formal training
and who write stuff that works in
really unusual ways or they're just
brilliant at it
they probably worked their butts off
it's not like they woke up one morning
and said i think i'll be a screenwriter
today
and spit out a masterpiece they may be
coming at it completely from left field
but they put the work into it so there's
the distinction
in that so there's no savant there's no
screenwriting savant where
they're able to emulate you know how
some these savants can can play a
masterpiece
without having known music in terms of
reading notes and things like that
i think there probably are but i think
they
also worked their butt off to
polish their craft but you never know
anything's quite possible
the real problem is that most
scripts suck seriously
and so those are hard numbers
that realistically 98 and some people
say it's 99.9
of all scripts submitted are
unreadable uh
for a variety of reasons but if you
don't have it all
working together on the page then the
script doesn't work
and so
how non-professional writers
come up with ideas
is really all across the board
from you know watching some movie
and wanting to basically just copy it
to having
like a fever dream that they wake up
from in a cold sweat and like
my god i gotta write that and maybe it's
brilliant
and and often they are uh
but almost always
they have to have the craft to execute
it properly
you know maybe it's a story their
grandfather told them about what
happened to them in world war ii or
whatever and
it electrifies them and they want to
turn it into a story
it might be just rolling ideas around in
their head and
[Music]
two odd ideas clank together at one
point you'll be like
that's a weird story you know sometimes
just colliding two different
stories together
the story alfred bester tells
he wrote an amazing book of short
stories called the golden man
and one of them is called fondly
fahrenheit
and it's about a robot a really high-end
robot in the future that
is the apex of robot invention and it
can literally
carve marble like michelangelo like
anything and he hires it out to do jobs
and it makes him a good living but it
gets overheated
and something goes wrong and the robot
kills the person it was with
so then he goes on the run with it and
puts it out for lesser jobs because
they're looking for the robot that can
carve like michelangelo
so now he has a teaching latin you know
on another planet
and it overheats and kills some so he
keeps going on the run and keeps
downgrading
what he's hiring the robot for and
bester talked about the creation of that
idea and the original idea was basically
that was that high-end robot
malfunctions
and he said it just wasn't enough it was
it was not a complex idea it was too
simple
and he shelved it and then
a number of years later he came across
the description of a psychological
malady in which one person thinks
they're another person where
i genuinely think i'm you
and it's like a it's like a mental
illness
and i act like i'm you and i interact
with you like i'm you
and he said that's really interesting
never heard of that before
and as he was like rolling it around in
his hands he reached up for the other
idea and he did what he called collide
them together to where this robot that
was malfunctioning
part of the malfunction is that the
robot thinks it's the master
and he said now that had some juice as a
story
and he made it into a fascinating short
story called fondly fahrenheit
and it's amazing you know and it's just
that
kind of thing and that's one of the
things that we do
in the two-year training program that
i'm doing
is that each student has
the the core of the course the 18-month
center of the course
we're constantly working on about
six to eight scripts at the same time
when we range from one to the next
so we might be working on an action
thriller then the next day we're on a
wacko comedy and the next day it's a
horror story and the next day is
like an adventure story so we're
changing gears constantly they're
learning different genres
and using the same tools and techniques
across a full spectrum of ideas
but they also have writing assignments
exercises to gain
facility with the individual skills
learning games and other things and one
of the things they have to do
is to spit out a new story idea every
day
and i emphasize like just
spit it out don't get precious with it
don't beat yourself up
and if
they love the idea they keep it in their
private folder if it's just
some dumb idea they just spit up with
they're not attached to it they put it
into the group story bin
so that anybody can work with it we play
with it we'll take one and go let's
create a dilemma for that
and if it begins to have legs then
that'll become one of the six to eight
scripts that we build
and in the process of them generating a
story idea every day
you know i'm saying to them don't worry
if it's dumb don't
try to come up with genius stuff just
keep spitting them out
because in the courses two years you'll
develop hundreds of ideas
and you'll get in the habit of spitting
them out and i said you know you may
find
that you end up colliding your
stupid bank robbery movie with your
crazy time travel story and like you
collide those two together and all of a
sudden you got a fun comedy
out of two lame looking ideas
so that's part of what i try to bring
to helping my students
acquire better attack as storytellers
and uh
just better facility creating stories
and being able to
recognize a lousy idea from a good one
um oh and by the way uh
the term attack as a storyteller came
from
the writer alfred bester
he um he was a big influence in on me as
a writer he wrote
two phenomenal novels science fiction
novels in 1954 and 56
one was the stars my destination the
other one is the demolished man
and he's in many ways considered one of
the absolute godfathers of science
fiction
he was like the primary influence on all
these people like heinlein
and um uh
arthur c clarke all these people like
worshiped him and
took off you know built upon the level
of energy that he brought
he was a he originally
wrote radio plays for the shadow
but it was a you know radio play the
shadow knows and comic book stories and
he said that kind of comic book writing
taught him a lot about attack as a
storyteller entertainment value
the outrageousness of great storytelling
and just he said writing for a radio
play you got to get
right honored he said start at white
heat and build from there
so his his his attack
as a storyteller has influenced me a lot
and i
try to
inspire my students to that level of
kind of ferocity like
you know it's like be a wild animal to
you to become a writer to be
domesticated creature to be told what to
do and
sit in a corner and salute you know it's
like
don't let anybody tell you how to do
this stuff
you know it's just it's just the
the whole society teaches people to
conform and sit down and shut up and
not it it doesn't say don't be original
but it
defuses in the in the in the sense of
diffuse like make it weaker diff usc but
also
defuse like to disarm a bomb
to take away the fangs and claws of
people
they people are domesticated in society
and we need wild animals you know we
need people that are out there
pushing the borders and seeing things in
an entirely new way and refusing to
accept the way things are
and that's so much the job of
storytellers is to
lead the way and inspire and show people
new ways to do things
um but hang on i'm so sorry to interrupt
you but
i like what you're saying but let me
just play the devil's advocate for a
second
if you don't know the rules you can't
break them kind of thing so
right when when you say to to push back
and don't let someone tell you what to
do
what if someone's this free sort of
loose cannon but they're going about
story
in the wrong way and then yeah okay
there's lots of different
there's really an infinite number of
approaches to
any kind of story or anything
you know like even just the way quentin
tarantino with pulp fiction
kind of flipped
storytelling in a certain way that we
hadn't seen done in movies much before
and did it really but he still had
really sophisticated structural
technique because he
had three different stories
written into a coherent hole so it
wasn't a mess
it was a gem so there's so many
different ways to tackle it
and what i'm talking about is
attack as a storyteller there's a
difference between
wildly explosive creativity as a
storyteller
and substantial craft as a dramatist
so there are
not so much rules for a dramatist
but a process of thinking habits of mind
like how do you make something work
uh for for traumatic presentation
real actors acting it out in front of an
audience and it grabs the audience it's
all about the audience
if a movie playing to an empty theater
has no power it's just shadows on the
wall
the power of the film resides in the
response of the audience
so
you want like wildly aggressive
storytelling and
rigorous technique as a dramatist it's
like
it's it's it's an interesting
intersection
of something that's organic and messy
and something that's a hard science like
medicine is a good example
because medicine taking on like
weird forms of cancer or something that
keep evolving and it's not like
they can control it they're just
bringing a rigorous science
to grapple with this organic thing
and us your story idea might be
unlike anything anybody's ever seen
and yet you still have to make it work
as a performance medium
so that your craft as a dramatist can
help you
wrestle that story into a
shape that makes it performable and
gripping
without sterilizing it you're not trying
to
defang its energy you're just trying to
make it so that it actually works so
that actors can really act it
and it really grabs an audience so it's
it's kind of like inherently
contradictory or it may sound that way
at first
but really it's just like
make your stories as explosively
creative as you
possibly can and
it's kind of like with the old samsonite
luggage where you
put a whole bunch of stuff in and then
you kneel on it and just click the
latches and then it's in there
if you can get that story into shape so
that it's
performable and grabs the audience then
it works
you know even if it's something as out
there as being john malkovich
where you're like watching the movie
going whoa look at that and you know
it's brilliant and it's
fun and it's different and it works it
grabs an audience it's actible
and yet it's coming not even from left
field but like
way out there and it's we need that kind
of fresh
energy and refusal to knuckle under to
normal story patterns and
even the craft of the dramatist the more
craft you have
see it comes down to principle and
method
there are certain principles that
underlie
what tend to make the tools work and
there are certain
methods that embody those principles so
like if the if you have certain
principles
that are active there are certain
methods that are created
that turn that principle into an
implement
and so that the particular tool you're
using
may not work exactly for the story
you're trying to tell
but it but you can adapt the story
because you're still
serving the same principle there just
may be a different mechanism that can
embody that principle so that you the
more
craft you have as a dramatist the more
you
can adapt because you're still
you're still achieving what you want to
achieve you just find a different way to
do it
can you give me an example of a
domesticated
writer and i'm not talking about
physically and at home staying home
during
covid just just someone that is in a
mindset of sort of the masses
and versus this wild unhinged feral
writer well generally those are
the writers of the scripts that don't
work of which there
are millions of them over you know
decades uh
so that even if you look for instance
at a movie that seems very calm on the
surface like ordinary people
it won best picture and a bunch of other
oscars i think in 80 or 81
something around there it's almost just
a parlor drama
like people sitting around a living room
arguing
but there's so much intensity and so
much ferocity and so much attack it
really goes right for the jugular vein
it's not making weak choices
it's making very strong choices and
really
making us take a good hard look at the
ugly or dysfunctional parts of ourselves
so that it has a tremendous attack a lot
of magnitude a lot of depth
so and that's like what i'm talking
about when i say domesticated i just
mean like
making small safe choices
where you know you're reading the script
and you like that you like
the pitch and then you read the script
and it's like
the pitch sounded so promising and they
just sat back and
you know phoned it in look at like at
this juncture they could have made
so many better choices but they made a
weak one and then
it just keeps it's like
you know just a lack of attack
you had talked about attention versus
intention
so that has to do with
what um in what anders erickson in his
book peak and in his whole career
talks about as deliberate practice
and that is that say that you're
a you're in training to be an olympic
ski racer
and it's a series of
individual skills that each of which has
to be
better than anybody in the world if
you're gonna win you like
every move you make so that
your coach is showing you video of
like as a skier i know that you to ski
right you're doing six things at the
same time
you have to do all at once and then
you're really good
but you have to learn each one in
isolation and then combine them so your
coach
would be saying you're leaning a little
too forward there and you're not popping
on your
when you when you change you know and
they'll and they'll isolate
certain things that they need to improve
upon like you keep you keep not
straightening your knee so they might
give them exercise
and have them do it a lot for instance
like one of my friends who was uh
played minor league hockey the junior b
they call it his coach would show them
how to do it and then say
go do that 50 000 times and then come
back it's that type of thing a
deliberate practice where your ski coach
would say you keep not extending your
elbow all the way
you gotta overcome that so every day
you'll do
that maybe a thousand times before you
do anything else and instead of going
i hate this you you you do it with full
attention and full intention
so that you're really paying attention
to it and
you're intending to like i'm gonna
master this
and yeah it's boring and everything else
but you're you stay
focused and that makes your brain
build the neural network stronger and
better whereas if you're not focused and
don't have strong intention
then you don't really get the the
cumulative benefit
in the brain structure that seats it as
a
deeply habitual so you once you've done
that
the whole season when you get into the
race then
every time you take a turn you never
miss that elbow lock
so that it becomes built in and that's
what eriksen called
deliberate practice and what they said
was that
they found that you don't want to give
the people your training drills but give
them short addictive games
they're literally doing the exact same
thing but you make an addictive game out
of it so that they can stay focused on
it better
you